there we go
thank you
did you say we'll just start the
conversation on whether or not this uh
should
the legislation let people start talking
okay and this is for 307. oh oh two nine
okay all right uh welcome
um I'm Andrew maneville sitting in for
the chair uh this is
a session on the uh HR 209 and I would
like to open
the hearing for input
thank you I recognize representative
infantine
when you first heard this bill over here
today both people with the Senate
electronic relative electronic weight
payment forecast
we had a lot of conversation whether or
not we felt uh
sorry we had a lot of discussion whether
or not we felt this should be mandated I
tell you that the personal issue I have
with these cards is while I may be
accused of being an old man and liking
the old way we did things versus
technology I remember my uh our clerk
John Mackey he'd like to check and
that's what our law says if you want to
check you can get a check and I
understand employers are trying to be
more efficient they're not doing their
own payrolls in a lot of respects
they're hiring payroll companies and the
payroll companies it's more costly for
them to issue checks and send them along
so they've gotten into these these cards
and I have no problem the cards the
problem I have with the cards is the
fees I really do you know the the one
thing you all remember your first job I
remember my first job I was a landscaper
you know made uh 450 an hour in high
school
and uh
you know
we we had a place where we could go and
cash our checks
but if I had to pay a dollar every time
I wanted to use a debit card or two
dollars uh
you know
every dollar counts
and for some a dollar a transaction or
two bucks a month or or something
doesn't matter
and then you say well you can take that
card and for one for no fee
take it all out and cash it
well I guess you can do that uh I just
don't like if we're not going to mandate
my buddy uh Mike Cahill we we have had
discussions all summer I enjoy emailing
with Mike and
um
there's certain things that we or I
don't like to mandate on businesses
that's what makes New Hampshire
different from a lot of things we don't
mandate on businesses what to do and we
try not to mandate employees having to
do things and I just unless you can come
up with a better mousetrap the way this
one was explained to us and the fees
associated with it no disrespect to a
company wanting to make business and
capital
um uh you know Capital way of doing
business
um I I uh capitalism I just I think they
make a lot of money off fees and I'm
just not a real fan
thank you Mr chairman
thank you chair recognizes
representative adjutant
thank you Mr chair
um I think even
um outside of the
um preference issue
um one of the big issues I see with the
pay cards is the insecurity of the
reliability of the payment
um if you have one of the pay cards
um odds are it's through a third party
of a third party
um and the actual process of
um getting their attention if your
payment is short late
um untraceable is far more complicated
than just uh reaching out to your
employer and asking for the issuance of
a second check
um I that that is terrifying
um if you are a person who like the
majority of people live paycheck to
paycheck
um and you have an unexpected turn in
the unavailability of the money that
you've earned then that can create other
problems
um as much as I would love to see pay
cards go entirely I would be content
with just uh not mandating it at this
time
thank you representative seaworth is
recognized thank you Mr chairman I'd
like to take the Devil's Advocate
position for a moment here
um and jostling my memory for what we
talked about uh back in the spring
first of all if my recollection serves
me
this is part of the bigger picture where
the what we're talking about is a what
the the law basically says what are
acceptable payments
and then secondly what is the order of
preference and if I remember the first
preference is the direct deposit if if
the employee has a bank account
and wants direct deposit the employer
must offer that so what we're talking
about here is what is the fallback
position and that fallback position is
if you either don't have a bank
or you don't want to use it for some
reason in a direct deposit capacity what
must the employer do if the employee
requests it the answer now and has been
for some time a check this law would
change that to make the default position
a pay card but again remembering that it
is if the employer likes a check and the
employee likes a check you could still
go that way it's just if there's a
disagreement what is the fallback
position so I wanted to make that clear
in everybody's mind as we're discussing
this
um the second thing that I recall is
when we talked about the fees in
in the discussion in the spring
we were assured that those fees don't
apply in the cases that we're talking
about that no employee should have to
pay fees to get their their paycheck and
it's only kind of extra stuff that might
incur fees and we as a committee we were
a little uncomfortable with that I don't
think we like taking some one bank's
assurance that this is the way it's
going to work when that protection's not
in law so that seemed to be a sticking
point but it's it's not entirely clear
to me what the full answer is on that so
having said all that is kind of a
rhetorical question to the committee
is there a solution to this
and because that's what we're here to
talk about today is If there is a better
version of this bill that might be
acceptable then I would vote to
recommend future legislation
if on the other hand the answer is you
know what this is just all wrong then I
I understand that as well but I wanted
to offer that as as uh
framework for our discussion here today
thank you
thank you representative the chair
recognizes representative Sullivan
thank you Mr chair
um
I I believe the
um representative seaworth is uh correct
in most of what he's saying but just to
clarify this bill would make it so that
the paper checks were no longer required
any employer who did not want to do
paper checks anymore could say I won't
do them and that fall back then would be
the um the payroll cards and the problem
with what we were told was that
um
each pay period
every employee would get one withdrawal
from that payroll card without charge
so that assumes that they are going to
go to the bank and take all of their
money out or as much money as they feel
they're going to use during that pay
period and um
take it from the card to avoid fees the
problem is that the people that who are
probably going to get stuck with the
payroll cards because they don't have a
bank or you know because they're living
in Dire Straits of some form they're not
the most sophisticated people in the
world and basically they would probably
be delighted to have a debit card that
they could use on a regular basis to you
know
buy a bag of chips or you know fill up
the tank or whatever and those
additional transactions are where the
additional fees come in so that I
believe is the objection that some of us
have to to the cards so
um
uh I think I do know what the solution
is the solution is um you know to leave
it alone I have no problem if the
payroll cards are available to an
employer an employee who both think that
they're desirable
um or think the fees are acceptable
um
but I think the current law says You
must provide a paper check if that's
what an employee asks for should stay in
place so I would suggest that no
additional legislation is necessary
thanks
thank you chair recognizes
representative adjutant
uh I also believe that
um representative seaworth's
recollection is correct as far as
um the uh
the belief among the financial
institutions that testified that
employees would have access to uh one
full out cash withdrawal
um
I guess the thing that I wonder is
would that be a thing that goes into
statute and would that statute be
constitutional because you can take the
um promise from the financial
institutions that the employees would
have access to that one withdrawal I
don't I wouldn't bet anything on that
but um point with standing
um I would be interested to see how the
um
like if you have a company that's based
out in California or Oregon or in a
different state that's New Hampshire
um and how would the
um legality of an enforcement of a one
withdrawal without fee hold up in the
wake of the Wayfarer decision a few
years ago I don't know
um that would be a gamble that I would
not want to take so I would concur
um on not moving legislation forward on
that
a chair rep recognizes uh representative
Seifert thank you Mr chairman and I want
to answer that to the best of my ability
because I think we did look at a similar
issue in this bill and the answer from
the Department of Labor on that similar
issue was that their enforcement ends
with the employer
so if an out-of-state Bank was not
living up to the legal obligations in
providing that pay card our department
of labor would go after the employer
for providing their employees with a
non-compliant pay card because you are
correct they can't regulate a bank that
isn't a New Hampshire business
the chair recognizes representative
infanting thank you Mr chair I think you
know one of the things that I've watched
over the last 20 years is as I've gone
from you know you had to make remember
guys some of you older folks you had to
get to the bank by five o'clock on
Friday to have cash
all not you
people
some of us are white-haired people here
remember you had to get to the bank by
Friday at five for money for the weekend
and if you didn't if you ran out of
money for the weekend cash and and you
didn't want to put on a credit card if
you're lucky you had a little uh card at
the grocery store where you could get
like a 50 you could cash a check at the
local grocery store because they had
already you know they already signed up
with them and then when these uh
bank cards showed up they were just
you could make a deposit or get cash
there was no what you could do with it
now so you know at almost 60 years of
age I've seen all this thing happen and
we try to push things and you know
sometimes they just happen by themselves
I don't know how many people out there
other than
um our our clerk who is an owner of his
company and still wants a paycheck every
uh
um week or whatever and gets that
um
how big of a problem is this
are there that many people that don't
want a a a card are there that many
people that don't want direct deposit
uh out there
is it that burden burdensome to
employers we didn't hear one employer I
believe that I recall come in and say oh
yeah it's a major cause for me it's a
major problem
um
and and since I am in the insurance
business and I see so much Computer
Fraud and hacking I've had three claims
this year of people getting in and
stealing money from people's accounts
um Unfortunately they let them in uh
computer uh genius over here
representative Prout uh probably knows
more about some of this nefarious stuff
than than I'd like to even know exists
um so
I don't know I like to err on this side
of caution I'm showing my age here but
um uh it would be nice
if it worked out
where employers could save money it
could be more efficient for the employee
but again whose problem are we trying to
solve here
usually If This Were big enough I would
think the Bia would be coming in here
saying guys this is a major problem this
is making us non-competitive with the
rather other states around us we need to
do this as a state to keep up to be able
to retain and keep employees and bring
them to New Hampshire I didn't hear it
thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative just anyone
else uh care to be heard on this
um piece of legislation
chair recognizes uh representative
avelini thank you Mr chairman
um
without beating the dead horse if a
payroll card is requested by a
employee at the under this
um
either the amendment or the original
bill
um there will be a you know roll-up cost
to having that card available to the
employee in a timely fashion
um
losing the card the original Bill had 24
hours of being notified so if they lose
it on a Saturday they're not going to
get a car till at least Monday morning
so that part is just unworkable in the
original bill it was taken out of the
amendment
but
um
we have no definition for a b or c we
have definitions for D and E
um
I think a b and c work very well
payroll cards again I think we only
heard from a payable company about
payroll cards
um and the checks again smaller
employers don't have Sometimes some
don't have access to or can't afford
larger payroll companies and use a
smaller company or even their accountant
to do their payroll at least where I'm
from
so most of them do
direct deposit or checks having payroll
cards you know again we have One Bank in
town
maybe that's not the bank that everybody
uses in town so would that be convenient
for the people that work for you
sometimes don't have Banks
so it would be difficult to have that
accessibility
with the cards and then you know the
same thing with the checks so I I think
leaving well enough alone
um going forward would be in our best
interest unless we have like
representative Andrew time said a call
to move to payroll cards as a permanent
solution to checks but we haven't heard
that yet thank you Mr chairman
thank you
uh chair represent recognizes
representative Prout
thank you Mr chairman so kind of how I
see this bill is all about changing what
the
uh Position will be if the employee and
the employer can't come to an otherwise
an agreement
um and currently the the fallback
position is a check and this would
change the fallback position to
uh the payroll card
um
and I think it's important to to keep in
mind that we're talking about what
happens when they actively disagree
um
something else that's in our current
laws that essentially if the employee
doesn't see the preference at all then
the fallback position is also a check
I'd be much more okay with changing the
default if nobody expresses an opinion
to a payroll call card
but changing the default when there's an
active disagreement
from uh from a check to a payroll card I
have a lot bigger qualm about because
there might be reasons that the employee
actively dislikes the payroll card
and so changing the default of the
employer if the employee says nothing
I'd be fairly okay with but changing the
default when there's an active
disagreement I think is something that
is much more contentious
thank you chair recognizes
representative Sullivan I just want to
remind all of us that the the real
default is the direct deposit that's
what almost everybody does
um I like direct deposit I think most of
us given that option would choose direct
deposit
um what we're dealing with are the
outliers the few people who um either
will not or cannot do direct deposit
most of them are people without bank
accounts so this is a small number of
people who will either get a check or
will get a payroll card
and in either case it's a very very
small number because the vast majority
of folks in New Hampshire are very happy
with direct deposit it's incredibly
convenient there's no worries about five
o'clock in the bank or fees or anything
else the money just shows up and you
start spinning it as soon as it's there
um so um you know I I just uh I think
it's it's not that much of an
inconvenience to require an employer to
provide a check
um to a very few people who simply are
unable to do the
direct deposit or you know we still have
situations I remember I think during the
hearing I referred to the people who
don't do
um direct deposits as dinosaurs
um I was approached by one of our
colleagues after the hearing with a
smile on his face but he says I guess
I'm a dinosaur
um but at any rate it's a very small
number of checks or a very small number
of payroll cards
um you'll never have a fee well you
could have a fee but basically you have
to be able to cash that check without a
fee and I
the payroll cards can very well turn
into fees for people who can't afford it
so again
um better to do nothing than to do
something that hurts folks thanks
thank you
do any other Representatives want to be
heard on this matter
seeing none
I will
request that someone offer a motion
I like this clerk me I have those uh
probably painted on your right hand oh
I think he does need them
oh yeah I do need one of those sorry
yeah
okay so I uh request uh that someone
offer a motion on this uh chair
recognizes representative adjective
thank you Mr chairman I move uh that no
further consideration be placed
um on SB
209 209.
um
second as received from representative D
Silvestro
um
and uh
we'll call the role will you call the
role representative of infantine
or do I do is no further
yeah okay all right
um so on the motion uh representative
infantine
who representative infantine should call
the rule oh I'm sorry no no I'm sorry I
was uh
uh avalani
yes if you agree with no further
legislation no if you do not yeah
there was a Callum oh representative
here representative board not here
turquo not here representative Prout
yeah
yeah representative Boyd
Sullivan yes representative Susie yes
representative Rudy yes Senator Cahill
vestro representative Schmidt
representative to me
and the Bouchard yes they're allergen
yes the representative seaworth yes
representative yes representative
mandible yes
12-0 motion
I guess for the recommendation of future
now for future legislation passes
thank you
we will take a
Mr chairman can we take a five minute
break so that clerk can get his work
done before we hear the next one yes
we're on a five minute break thank you
if you don't mind
foreign
our second and final bill has to do with
uh Senate Bill 377 FN relative to the
diagnosis of post-traumatic stress
disorders in state troopers
and I thought this was
yes yes
this
darn it I didn't uh bring the right page
I didn't believe this had to do with the
the
um the workers compensation to and from
so I'm sorry I don't have the amendment
with me I apologize that was the
original bill so um I will open that uh
the open this
um interim study
hearing to anyone who would like to
opine
okay representative attitude
representative Sullivan remember m c
worth
uh Mr chairman can we start off with a
motion and then move to discussion after
is that
I don't mind is there any objection to
that
uh you're
right you're welcome to make a motion I
would move to consider future
legislation
um and if I could briefly speak to that
motion yes you may
um I'm a little confused now
um because of the new title and the lack
of the amendment I think the underlying
bill has a good point
um and because it's essentially
non-binding
um
I think it could use more consideration
after but I don't
I'm kind of confused as what we're
talking about now
um so I suppose that's where I would be
at on it observe Sullivan
if it's okay with the chair I'd like to
take a minute to try to review exactly
what this bill is about so we can
actually know what we're talking about
um and my recollection is that this bill
was dealing with state troopers who
um were in uniform
in their patrol car and moving to and
from
workplaces such as a construction zone
where they were technically not on duty
um and the The
Fairly convoluted situation I found it
interesting to learn about but basically
it meant that if
um
if they ended up in a workers comp
situation an injury on their way to this
work site
they witnessed some sort of lawlessness
they as is appropriate they act on it
and somehow end up becoming injured
dealing with a Law Enforcement issue on
the way to a
um a construction site
they want to be considered on duty and
therefore or at least they want workers
comp to cover them even though they're
not on duty I guess is the way it worked
and
as I recollect some members of the
committee
upon reviewing this thought that perhaps
there might be other members of law
enforcement that may also benefit from
this um
uh type of provision and I believe that
is how it ended up
um as a interim study bill and you know
the the question before us is whether or
not
um any um for the legislation ought to
be suggested
um I also recall discussion during the
um the hearing of
um whether or not there is any pressing
need expressed from
the patrol officers and um it there
wasn't a lot of testimony to that effect
I mean I believe their organization was
came forward but there was not a lot of
other others so
and if somebody has a clear or a
different recollection I'd be delighted
to have it clarified but um hopefully
that that's helpful
I believe your recollection is sound
representative representative uh
thank you Mr chairman and I too will
agree uh representative Sullivan's
recollection matches my own and I think
um uh
yes it there was some question on the
committee does this bill not go far
enough was it too narrow in its scope
or maybe even was it unnecessary is it
something that workers comp already
would do and isn't necessary in law and
the hold up as I recall was that we
didn't get that kind of information that
um at least some of us thought was
necessary to being able to act on the
bill
um so
I also would agree with my colleagues
that it would be appropriate to resubmit
this bill and to get that extra detail
that seemed to be absent this time
around and I think we could
we could work with it in a future
session thank you thank you
representative
thank you Mr chairman
um my recollection mostly matches uh
what has been said already
um and I recall that my big concern was
the extreme specificity of the language
before us to a certain set of
circumstances where we could clearly
identify circumstances very similar but
just outside the wording
that we don't understand didn't
understand why they were excluded
um for example if two officers are going
to a construction site together one in
the Opera driver's seat of the vehicle
one the passenger seat the driver's
covered but the passenger is not
under the wording we had before us uh
similarly if the officer you know
stopped to do something and the car was
off he was standing right at the
driver's door he wasn't operating the
vehicle it wouldn't be covered there
were so many
the language was so specific to a
certain set of circumstances we didn't
understand if there was a reason driving
that
or if it was just the by happenstance
those words were chosen and we didn't
have any testify any testimony to
clarify any of that confusion or
questions that we had and so that's why
we placed it in term study
as far as I can recall
thank you
representative
thank you Mr chairman
um there was several questions that
remained still remain unanswered one is
why this isn't covering
um County Sheriffs they take their
vehicles home this also doesn't cover
local officers that take their vehicles
home
um fishing game fishing game as well uh
Fire Marshals fire wardens I mean we can
go across the the whole Spectrum
um
that's one and
the the problem I had with it is it
relative to the diagnosis of
post-traumatic stress disorder and state
troopers when it was simply traveling
from their house to a off-site job you
know technically off duty but in a car
and in the uniform of the day how does
that transfer to a post-traumatic stress
disorder and straight Troopers and
expanding that definition
that's was also unanswered
um if it's just some simple coverage to
and from it doesn't seem to be it seems
to be a simple workman's comp but to
expand the definition of post-traumatic
stress disorder seems to be a little
more we need a little more on that
thank you Mr chairman
representative Sullivan
we heard nothing about post-traumatic
stress nothing so I have to believe that
this is one of those bills that the
other body hijacked and repurposed
um so I think we can set the
post-traumatic stress aside
um and I'm not
um I agree that there are unanswered
questions there are folks that might
benefit from it I think at the time my
sense was
what harm can it do to go ahead and pass
this and if other people need to pile on
we can expand it in the next session
that didn't happen
um
but um I I would be supportive of uh you
know encouraging the uh
involved folks to bring this back answer
some of the questions that we've got and
give it another go so I I would support
that
thank you representative Rudy thank you
Mr chairman this is one of those cases
that um
leaves a little at a lower open and the
insurance companies have very sharp
lawyers and they're not going to want to
pay anything they don't have to so I see
this an incident happening and it winds
up in the Supreme Court because the
Department of Labor won't be able to
solve it
thank you
I would encourage us to go next year and
do our job
there was no Sullivan like you I also
wanted to try to see if we can come up
with something and I did offer to
compromise to
um the lobbyist for the Troopers
Association they took it back to their
members and they were afraid the
compromise was narrow when they wanted
it broader just for
edification of what goes on with workers
compensation
if you are driving if I am driving to a
work site
and that's where I go to work that day I
am not covered under my employer's
workers compensation from my home to my
work site however if I'm a roving
superintendent or I leave my office I am
going to four different calls or I go to
four or five different jobs that is
considered on the job
because I'm I'm not just going to the
office to start my day or wherever the
wherever the place is I'm not going to
the restaurant to start my day
um
um you know that's not covered however
if
uh my my boss tells me to go pick up
four different supplies at food at four
different places I am on I am I'm
covered so that is kind of the law there
was an article I am it's probably
sitting on my desk there was a actually
a case in New Hampshire that went all
the way to the New Hampshire Supreme
Court this year
um about this there's this whole concept
of the Department of Labor and within
the workers compensation about this
concept of on the way to work when is it
um and um I think that ruling will be
important to Future legislation
but there's no question that Troopers
are driving vehicles and anyone and you
know one of the things we had a
discussion was well in uniform well
uniform is a officer's uniform or an
undercover officers and plain clothes so
whatever the uniform of the day is
whatever that is
um
they are going to uh their uh they're
going to
um
target shoot
because they have to do that as
requirements they're going to continued
education they're going to continue
training they're going to a detail when
they're leaving their home
so her first question is well should
they be covered on the weight of those
things I my opinion as an insurance guy
I think yes they're driving a company
vehicle they're on the way to do that as
part of their job then the question was
well if they happen to see something
going where they have to
there's a bad situation going down there
a mile away even though they're off duty
they call and say hey I'm here I'm going
to go or they stop at the side of the
road to see a stranded vehicle or a car
accident
um and um they have to engage so when
they engage
that's when it should start
um
again all these things get complex
and they have to be well defined and
um I think the Supreme Court case will
help
um that happened this year but uh
without question I don't think there's
anyone here that does not want a Sheriff
Fish and Game officer state trooper
to be injured in the line of duty and
someone have a technicality and say well
you know you kind of weren't on duty yet
you know kind of like yeah I don't think
anyone's here to do that that's not the
New Hampshire way so I'm in agreement
with all of my colleagues
um that uh would like to see this for
future
legislation
any additional comments
okay
so representative adigent moved
recommendation for future legislation
I'll second that a second by Sullivan
um
so if you would like this for future
legislation you would vote Yes if not
you would vote no representative avalani
yes
Calum not here representative Nike not
here love not here
Warden turcotte representative Prout yes
representative boy representative Huff
representative Sullivan yes
representative Susie representative Rudy
yes representative Cahill representative
D Silvestro
representative Schmidt thank you
representative to me
from the Bouchard representative yes
representative Mandeville yes
representative seaworth yes
representative wrote yes
12-0
you want to write the blurb
I'm kidding
today is the 13th
all right I have no further business
in front of this committee
um representative meneval uh Mr chair
didn't affect my vote but I would be uh
appreciative if you could either provide
information about where to find that
Supreme Court case or maybe send
something around if you don't recall now
that would help us look at that for
future reference I will I'll send it
around it's on my on my desk in a pile
somewhere thank you could I also say I
appreciate the Chairman's efforts and
this entire committee and it's been an
honor to serve with you
well thank you representative menever
and representative Hoff will not be uh
joining the legislature next year there
and uh to me
um enjoy I didn't realize uh 84
wonderful years I didn't realize you
were not running again sir so thank you
very much for your service and uh for
being on this committee
well I may have not always made you
happy I hope you enjoyed being here all
of you on the committee representative
Sullivan
thank you Mr chairman
um this is my this is a third labor
committee I've served on and uh I have
to say that I've been proud to be a part
of all three of those committees they've
all been differently made up
um the first committee I was on was a
republican majority the second one I was
uh lucky enough to be chair of the third
one
um is had chairman infantine is uh the
lead in the on the committee and um
I just want to say that if
by some Stroke of Luck I should be in
the position of chairing this committee
again I hope I'm able to do chair it as
effectively and fairly as chairman
infantine has I will uh I hope I did it
that way when I had the opportunity and
I would always keep in mind the manner
in which chairman infantein ran this
committee and I wish the rest of my
colleagues were here but it is what it
is
um I just want to Express gratitude for
the the manner in which this committee
has been conducted and it's been the
lead of chairman infantein that made
that difference so thank you
thank you appreciate that all right guys
it's been fun we will uh good luck to
all of you and if I don't see you in
your future endeavors and good luck all
of you are running again and and if
we're whoever is fortunate
to have been re-elected by uh our peers
or we will uh not our peers but our
constituents and we'll hopefully I'll
see you here in December
uh there will be one study committee
meeting held at one o'clock uh
representative uh Sullivan abalani
seeworth and I you know oh sorry who am
I missing Kavanaugh and Senator
Kavanaugh will be here one o'clock this
is we will be um coming to the final
um report on our OSHA
study bill
oh
if you want to hang out for that you can
if not have a wonderful day everyone